und ging so an den schuhen vorbei nach
hinten und der hanse und pulli und ich
dachte das ist der geilste pulli den du
jemals gesehen hast etwas glaubt jetzt
willkommen einem neuen video für heute
mal wieder was heißt mal wieder so was
gab es eigentlich noch nicht ich habe
mir gedacht komm du hast richtig bock
drauf so dass einfach mal zu machen weil
ich ja in letzter zeit auch vor allem so
instagram noch mal extra für mich
entdeckt habe bzw bisschen neu für mich
entdeckt habe wenn ihr das noch nicht
kennt dann checkt das war aber
eigentlich kennt ihr das hier
wahrscheinlich was du diese outfit
sachen angehen jetzt halt irgendwie
coole klamotten so wenn man youtube
macht und auf youtube ein bisschen
länger markt und dann irgendwelche
kleinunternehmen gleich mal auf einen
zukommt und einem klamotten schicken
dann denkt man sich schon so jung das
kann man damit kombinieren das kann man
damit kombinieren und so weiter und so
fort also man kommt irgendwie in diese
sache viel mehr rein also würde ich kein
youtube machen ich glaube ich sehe aus
wie der normale mensch der welt aber so
sehe ich heute nicht mehr oder
wir wollen auch gar nicht lange lahm und
ich habe in letzter zeit wirklich ein
paar coole sachen neue zugeschickt
bekommen ich war noch einmal selber
stoppen und habe mir hier so ein paar
sachen also die die mir davon wirklich
am besten gefallen habe ich rausgesucht
die zeige ich euch jetzt mal und ihr
könnt ja mal schreiben was ihr davon
haltet ob ihr die auch cool findet oder
nicht
ja und ich würde sagen ich fange direkt
bar an mit einer jacke weiße jacke kann
schildern und ausziehen und die passt
auch quartier zu fan ja dass ich diese
jacke ist einfach schwarz und weiß ist
von zara und jetzt brauche ich auch
irgendwie so einen geilen trick wie ich
die anziehen ich habe mir da was überleg
mal gucken ob es auch geil aussieht
später im schnitt wenn nicht dann habe
ich leicht verpackt aber passt mal auf
dem band babybird abu dhabi
das ist die jacke was soll man dazu noch
sagen ich bin die echt cool
die war von 55 fest sollte die wahl von
55 euro auf 510 euro runtergesetzt oder
540 weiß mehr über auf jeden fall war
das gras habe ich gedacht ich komm'
nimmt sie direkt zehn stück von mit ok
dann kommen jetzt zum nächsten teil und
zwar erstmal zu den t shirts richtig
coole t-shirts zu meine drei lieblings t
shirt zurzeit bzw eigentlich hatte ich
zwei freunden noch gar nicht an
meine drei regal und zwar erst mal
dieses shirt in beige ist in khaki ja
dieses shirt in khaki tasten auch mal
kurz aus näheres soll
pm bad iburg ein nobody vom ammersee
fackelschein ich finde das shirt richtig
cool ist auch ein bisschen länger
eigentlich wollte ich so was nie tragen
weil ich dachte immer diese längeren
sachen den fand ich vor einem halben
jahr nicht so cool ein zwei sachen habe
ich davon jetzt auch die ein bisschen
länger sind oder auch drei oder vier
keine ahnung wir kommen zum nächsten
jahr das ist auch in der gleichen oder
ähnlichen farbe bisschen dunkler
gehalten das ist fast schon grün oder
ist eigentlich grün von der marke
autonomen die haben ein paar coole
sachen zugeschickt auf den fall
abschenken ist und in der video
beschreibung wenn ihr bock hat das test
meist auch mal aus so sieht das ganze
aus kann man natürlich auch noch einiges
ausmachen ärmel umkrempeln paar löcher
rein machen oder hier oben den kahlen
rausschneiden habe ich zwar noch nie
gemacht aber kann ich ja mal
ausprobieren genau autonomen davon habe
ich das gleiche noch in weiß das sieht
halt praktisch genau so aus ich glaube
das muss jetzt nicht noch mal extra
anziehen und dann haben wir noch einen
richtig geilen pullover zugeschickt den
zeige ich euch auch mal cool und zwar
ist aus dieser pullover der ist in
probieren wir mal kurz an zack zack okay
ist sehe ich aus wie ein
eishockeyspieler bei der voll breites
oben ja hier sind natürlich die einen
anderen löcher drin ich finde sowas
richtig cool man kann sich darüber
streiten ob das vielleicht ein paar
löcher zu viel sind aber mir gefällt
gibt natürlich leute den gefällt es gibt
leute denen gefällt das nicht ich bin
cool als wenn man mich jetzt ganz sehen
würde würde ich nicht so fett aussehen
mich grad außen also wirklich ein
richtig geiler pulli dankeschön dafür
und jetzt kommen jetzt zu einem weiteren
pulli der mir auch obwohl hier
willkommen erstmal noch zu nehmen zu den
zahlen der auch cool ist aber nicht zu
meinen absoluten favoriten ja es ist ein
ganz normaler pool in weniger normales
wird anderes nur das ist so in carmaux
in camos teil fand ich auch cool habe
ich direkt mitgenommen für keine ahnung
wie viel beim bmw das habe ich jetzt
schon zu dritten mal gemacht
auf jeden fall ich finde dass bahn
konnte ich jetzt gut machen
so sieht das ganze aus finde ich richtig
cool vor allem kann man den auch gut im
habe ich wieder eine passende hose ist
wird meine stimme habe ich mir auf jeden
fall noch eine passende hose dazu geholt
im ähnlichen das ist wieder kaffee
diese hose lohnt sich jetzt nicht wenn
ich das an ziehe ich glaube das kann ich
dann nochmal im nachhinein zeigen also
das nehme ich später noch mal auf das
ganze outfit und noch diese schuhe auf
jeden fall noch diese schuhe die sind
von jordan unter john keine ahnung ich
kenne mich damit aus ich kaufe einfach
das was gut aus jedes jahr egal wie das
heißt vielleicht irgendwann werde ich
noch mal ein bisschen putzen auf jeden
fall sind die drei tage alt und dreckig
warum auch immer ich weiß nicht und so
sieht das ganze im ganzen outfit
zusammen drinnen aus
so willkommen zurück
ja und jetzt kommen wir wirklich zu
meinen absoluten favoriten
ich dachte so ok kommen du hast schon
genug geld ausgegeben heute kaufst du
dir nichts mehr
und dann wenn ihr okay schuhe braucht
ihn ich hatte noch gedacht er kommt für
schuhe nimmst du noch mal ein bisschen
geld mit und dann kam ich in diesem pulk
locker laden foot locker kennen ja
wahrscheinlich die meisten von euch und
ging so an den schuhen vorbei nach
hinten und der hansen pulli und ich
dachte das ist der geilste pulli den er
jemals gesehen hast ich weiß nicht warum
aber er gefällt mir so krass gut ist
auch von der marke jordan und ich zeige
euch den markt einiges da gar nichts gar
nichts weiß ich nicht es ist einfach
jojo was geht alles gut bei dir bei mir
auch nicht gesehen
jetzt fragen sich wahrscheinlich so die
meisten von euch etwas findet er daran
so geil aber ich weiß nicht ich finde
dieses silberne logo hier richtig geil
dann dieses hier außen und dann hab ich
dann einfach noch mal mitgenommen ihr
könnt immer in die kommentare okay wir
ziehen erst mal kurz an kann sogar sein
dass ich den schon einem ein oder
anderen video an hatte ich glaube den
hatte ich schon einmal an
man bin ich durch den wollt ihr euch so
präsentiert er kleiner geworden kann das
sein baum mama warum ist mein pony
kleiner ende ist echt ein bisschen
kleiner habe ich das gefühl naja ist
trotzdem noch geil auf jeden fall ihr
könnt ja meine kommentare schreibt oder
wenn ihr wenn ihr auch findet er ist
schon cool
könnt ihr mir gern man doch nach oben da
lassen ansonsten waren es glaube ich
sogar alle sachen ja also alle coolsten
sachen meine favoriten wenn euch das
video gefeiert und ihr sowas vielleicht
nochmal möchtet dann zeigt das doch
einfach mit dem daumen nach oben würde
mich sehr freuen ansonsten schreibt in
die kommentare was ihr so für klamotten
tragen was würdet ihr cool checkt
instagram ab aber nicht vergessen und
nicht zu verpassen ich muss ein bisschen
luft holen wir sehen uns dann am sonntag
bin ich wieder oder am montag ich weiß
es nicht genau handle sei jetzt in die
video days und gamescom in köln da bin
ich auch auf jeden fall ein bisschen
rumlaufen geile eindrücke sammeln und
viele von euch treffen ich freue mich
mega drei leute wir sehen uns peace
j